on ne quitte pas l'asie avec du cinéma
cette fois et la sortie d'un film de
wong kar-wai qui est toujours un
événement il avait fait sensation
dernier festival de cannes le
réalisateur d' in the mood for love a
choisi jude law et la chanteuse norah
jones pour incarner cette nouvelle
histoire d'amour
marie-jo juin vincent bouffartigue vous
avez du mal à mettre un nom sur son
visage mais cette mélodie d'une seconde
for love de wong kar-wai l'a gravé dans
nos mémoires
pour le cinéaste chinois de la musique
qui à la place d'un acteur c'est
peut-être pour cela qu'il a choisi la
chanteuse norah jones pour le rôle
principal
elle interprète une jeune femme au coeur
brisé qui vient s'épancher auprès d'un
barman new yorkais puis disparu pas
facile de devenir l'héroïne de wong
kar-wai lorsqu'on sait que le
réalisateur écrit le scénario pendant le
tournage est presque un père avec moi il
était à mes côtés me toucher l'épaule et
me diriger avec une grande douceur et
jamais je me suis sentie situe bien ni
même comme une débutante
son originalité c'est de faire avancer
l'histoire en prenant chez des gens les
dans leur vie de tous petits moments de
tout petits détails
las vegas est un voyage au coeur de
l'amérique que la jeune femme entreprend
pour se reconstruire
on y croise avec elle de beaux
personnages écorchés par la vie
le film par degré si l'on peut prendre
elle veut mettre le plus de distance
possible entre son amour et l
physiquement et moralement
ce n'est pas le voyage en soi qui compte
ici moi comme ça même s'ils vont kawaii
semble avoir cédé aux sirènes des
studios américains en tournant en
anglais on retrouve dans ce film ça pas
totalement original avec en prime l'un
des plus beaux baisers de cinéma